[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we had started
discussing
the formulation of the torsion problem
in terms of the parental stress function
and we had noticed or we had found that
this prandtl stress function approach
using this i uh
the torsion problem can be presented
in terms of this governing equation del
square psi
is equal to minus 1. we had also found
out this important condition that psi is
equal
to constant on the periphery and
so let me just uh box that
is a constant on the periphery and we
also found out
uh this particular relation for the
torsional
rigidity which is given by this gj so we
had this
rather big expression now uh
so let me just box that also
now what we want to do in today's video
is to dig in a little deeper
so that we are in a position
to solve a few problems
uh which uh so we should be in a
position to solve problems which are
uh which of course involve the circular
cross section
uh and certainly uh the main motivation
of
studying this chapter in this detail uh
which is to
which is to address non-circular cross
sections also
so what we have to do first of all
uh is to look at two categories of cross
sections
the first category is referred to as the
simply connected region
okay it's a rather uh
mathematical sounding expression
and it is certainly that but it can be
understood in a
in a very simple fashion by just looking
at a general example
of which is to say that we have a cross
section like this
okay so one might immediately ask
sorry about that spelling mistake there
one might immediately ask uh as to what
is the distinguishing feature of this
special
uh simply connected region
well uh as far as long as we confine
ourselves to this two dimensions
uh a simply connected region is one
which does not have
any holes in it okay it is as simple as
that
so as long as we have a cross section
which does not have any holes in it
uh it is a simply connected region so
for example
a shaft with a circular cross section
with an elliptical cross section
with a rectangular cross section those
are all examples of cross sections which
may as well be referred mathematically
to as a simply connected region however
if you have
a shaft with a with an annular
cross section then that annular cross
section okay
so suppose we have
a cross section like this
which has a hole like this
and not just one hole it can have
multiple holes
okay it can have multiple holes in it
so if you have a cross section like this
uh
then this cross section is no longer
simply connected okay so that would be
referred to as a multiply connected
region
all right of course these definitions
associated with the simply connected
domain or the region
multiplex region of domain it becomes
much more
i mean you need to be much more
mathematically
rigorous if you have to go to three
dimensions
okay but that is not our concern here so
now first of all going to this simply
connected region
you see the easiest thing that we can
immediately arrive at while considering
the simply connected region
is by noting that there is only
one periphery present here as opposed to
this multiply connected region where
there are multiple peripherals so you
see this is a periphery
that's the outer periphery this is an
inner periphery this is another inner
periphery this is another inner
periphery
okay unlike that here we have only one
periphery
so if we just go back and look at this
condition
psi is equal to constant on the
periphery then
uh and we had also mentioned in that
video that
because it is a constant and because the
governing equation here
as well as the definitions of the
stresses
they only involve the the derivatives of
this frontal stress function psi
uh it really doesn't matter what
constant we may add or subtract from
this side
okay it can be any constant okay so
since it can be any constant
uh perhaps it is uh easiest
to consider this side to be a zero on
the on the single periphery that we
actually have here okay so what we
really do while actually solving
problems is that for a simply connected
region
we considered the psi okay we considered
the site
to be zero
on the periphery and please note that
this is the only periphery that we have
here
okay well
how does that help us you see
our our governing equation is del square
psi is equal to minus 1
that remains unchanged by this extra
condition of
i is equal to 0 why because you have to
be very careful to note that psi
is certainly not zero over the entire
periphery over the entire domain
or over the entire region we are only
considering psi to be 0
on the periphery that's it so this
governing equation it does not change
next we have said that psi is equal to
constant generally
that's what we had found out that psi is
a constant on the periphery and that we
have just said that psi is equal to zero
on the on the boundary okay so this
particular
uh consideration that psi is equal to
zero on the periphery
that really helps us to zero in uh on
the boundary okay on the on a very
specific boundary
we are no longer saying that psi is some
arbitrary constant the boundary we are
actually saying now that size
is equal to zero on the boundary and
what are we left with really
we are left with the consideration of
the torsional
rigidity and that is present here
and you clearly see that this
integration uh
involves the sign this integration is
over the entire periphery and it does
involve the sign so
can we not write this so let me go to
the next page and write that again
gj is equal to minus twice g
i click integral this is over the intel
periphery x n x
plus y and y i is common
you can see here i is present here psi
is present here so what we have is x and
x plus y and y times psi
times psi this integration is with
respect to the variable s
that tracks the periphery now because we
have just now
considered our psi to be equal to zero
over then that periphery
we can immediately say that this entire
integration
is going to be zero so all that we will
be left with
uh in the final expression for this
torsional rigidity
is this uh second term so this is 4g
times
integration of psi t
okay you must be very careful to note
that this second integration is over the
entire domain
and please do not make the mistake of
saying that psi is equal to 0 here
it is not the size over the entire
domain
this side that is that is present here
that because
uh our our concern here is with this
integration which is
over the periphery that is why this
first integration is equal to 0
okay so now we will just end up for the
torsion rigidity
as this first term is 0 plus 4g
integration i ta
that's it okay so uh
for example uh what we can do is as a
very simple example we can take that
take the take the simplest of uh
situations which is a circular
cross section and there uh
while solving that problem in terms of
this parental stress function
what we can do is we can just consider
the side
uh to be uh so let me just show that
quickly
so far as an example
a circular cross section
so
take the psi to be equal to
a times um
r square minus x square minus
y squared
and it is extremely important to note
here
that the primary motivation of
taking up this prandtl stress function
approach
is actually very nicely satisfied here
because
we have been supplied with the
information that our cross section
is circular in nature and in the very
step first step of our solution
procedure
we are utilizing that information
regarding the geometry
we are not so our uh
our method of solving this problem
is not based on some arbitrary guesswork
with the with the hope that one day it
will give us some
useful solution rather it is directly
connected
to the specific geometry which has been
given to us which is circular
because we are utilizing that
information in setting this up
okay so our so our choice
of this particular expression r square
minus x square minus y square
is governed by this information which is
given to us
that the cross section is circular okay
of course this r
is the outer radius of this cross
section this k
however is a general constant okay we
don't know about this k
so uh what what we can do is uh we can
utilize this governing equation to see
what information it gives us
l square psi is equal to minus 1 so
basically
this is saying that del square psi
del x square plus del square psi
del y square is equal to minus 1.
so this is minus twice
a and then again we have
minus twice k equal to -1
this is 4k is equal to 1
so k is equal to 1 by 4
therefore our psi
is equal to 1 by 4
r square minus x square minus y square
now that we have this expression we can
very well uh
try to find out the torsional rigidity
let's let's see what it gives us so for
the torsional rigidity we have the
expression
that gj is equal to
4g i
d a integrated over the entire area
so this is uh
is like this 1 by 4
r square minus x square minus y square
and see if i have to convert this to
so now i just want to write it like this
a but if i have to convert this
properly to a double integration over
the x and y
then we can proceed
but i think you will all agree
that it will be easier if i just convert
from this x y coordinate system to the
polar coordinate system
okay so in that case we all know that
this can be equivalently written as
capital r square minus small r square
no problem there and this particular
d a that
becomes
twice by r dr so what we are effectively
doing here
is that is writing this d a as
uh as
as rd theta of
r uh sorry so d
a we are actually writing this as r d
theta d r okay and
uh so i have skipped a couple of steps
in between
and this is basically just a repetition
of what you have learned probably
in 100 undergraduate days engineering
mathematics but
uh i'll just say so there will be a
double integration
1 over r and the other over theta
and because this is a perfectly axis
symmetric situation
all of these terms will go outside the
integration with respect to theta
and that theta integration will be going
from zero to twice pi
and that's how we'll be ending up with
this twice pi
and finally this thing will just uh
give us a nice expression so let me just
do it so this of one by one these four
cancels let me just
remove that
so this is twice pi
capital r square rdr
and please note that this is integration
from zero to capital r
minus
pi spy 0 to capital r
rq
dr
so what we have here is
basically r squared by 2
minus twice pi
r 4 by 4
so this 2 cancels with this 2 this 2
cancels with this 2.
so we have basically a pi r to the power
4 here minus 5 r to the power 4
up by 2 so overall this becomes
half g
by r4 you can clearly see here that
or you can compare with what you know
from your undergraduate days
that the j the polar moment of inertia
that is
half pi r to the power 4
that matches nicely with what we have
obtained using this frontal stress
function
but this should not be the end of things
because we do want to go to cross
sections which are not
circular and that will be using for that
will be using examples
uh illustrated through the use of
symbolic python and jupyter notebook
all right on this note uh i'll end this
video uh
and in the next one we'll go to a
discussion of the
multiply connected region very much